D
A LITTLE MORE QUICKLY THAN
ANTICIPATED LESS TALK ABOUT BOTH
OF THESE ISSUES FORMER GOVERNOR
OF ARKANSAS MIKE HUCKABEE WHO
JOINS US NOW PAIRED GOVERNOR
GREAT TO SEE YOU THIS MORNING.
YOU'VE HEARD ALL THE REPORTS
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT, WHAT
IS YOUR REACTION?
>> WELL, IT'S TROUBLING TO SEE
THESE ARE CHILDREN ARE EXPLOITED
FOR THIS TO COME TO PEOPLE TO
COME TO THE UNITED STATES TO
IMMIGRANT THERE ARE THOSE WHO
COME BECAUSE THEY DESPERATELY
WANT THE AMERICAN DREAM.
THEY WANT TO LIVE HERE, THEY
WANT FREEDOM, THEY WANT
OPPORTUNITY.
THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
MADE AMERICA WONDERFUL COUNTRY
AND THANK GOD THERE COME FROM
ALL OVER THE WORLD TO MAKE US A
BETTER COUNTRY.
AND THEN THERE ARE THOSE WHO
WANT TO EXPLOIT THE AMERICAN
DREAM PER THEY WANT TO HURT
PEOPLE.
THEY WANT TO TRAFFIC CHILDREN
PER THEY WENT TO ABUSE THEM FOR
THEY WANT TO SELL DRUGS.
WE HAVE EVERY RIGHT AND REASON
TO KEEP THOSE PEOPLE OUT FOR YOU
CANNOT KEEP ANYBODY OUT YOU
CANNOT PROCESS THE RIGHT ONES IF
YOU DON'T CONTROL THE ORDER.
THE BORDER POLICY IS A CHICKEN
THAT HAS COME HOME TO ROOST.
IT IS TIME TO PLUCK THE CHICKEN
AND MAKE SURE WE HAVE CONTROL
THE BORDERS AND CONTROL THE
PEOPLE WHO TRULY DESERVE TO COME
HERE.
AND WE WANT TO COME HERE.
>> GOVERNOR RACHEL TALKED ABOUT
THIS IN RIGHTLY SO.
AS A FORMER GOVERNOR STATES TO
RECEIVE THESE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, FAMILY, KIDS HOW TO
ABSORB INTO A COMMUNITY THAT IS
ALREADY OVERWORKED, OVERTAXED?
SCHOOLS AT CAPACITY BUT HOW DO
YOU ABSORB THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY?
THE TAXPAYERS SPEND A WHOLE
BUNCH OF MONEY THEY WOULD NOT BE
SPENDING.
HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS WITH PEOPLE
COMMEND ILLEGALLY THEY COME INTO
A SITUATION THEY TYPICALLY ARE
COMING IN, IMPOVERISH FOR THESE
ARE NOT PEOPLE FLYING IN A
PRIVATE JET PICKING UP A LIMO
AND DRIVING TO A HOME THEY JUST
BOUGHT WHICH MEANS YOU ARE GOING
TO PUT THEM IN YOUR MEDICAID
PROGRAM.
YOU'RE GOING TO PAY ALL THEIR
HEALTH CARE EXPENSES BUT YOU'RE
GOING TO PUT THEM INTO YOUR
SCHOOLS, THEY ALL THE
EDUCATIONAL EXPENSES AT SEVERAL
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR PER
CHILD AND IT MEANS YOU'RE ALSO
ALSO GOING TO SUBSIDIZE FOOD.
GOING TO SUBSIDIZE HOUSING.
AND WENT ALL OF THIS HAPPENS,
WHO IS PAYING FOR THAT?
THE TAXPAYERS IN THOSE STATES
THAT I CAN CITE EVERY GOVERNOR
IN AMERICA ANYONE WHO SELLS HER
BRAIN FUNCTION THERE'S A FEW
THAT APPARENTLY DON'T.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT NOT LOVING
PEOPLE IT'S NOT ABOUT BEING
COMPASSIONATE IT'S ABOUT NOT
WANTING TO PUT AN UNFAIR BURDEN
ON THEIR ALREADY BURDENED
TAXPAYERS AND PUSHING THINGS
INTO THEIR BUDGET THEY SIMPLY
CANNOT AFFORD.
HERE'S THE OTHER RUBBED THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS NOT PAYING
FOR ALL THOSE EXPENSES THEY ARE
LEAVING IT TO THE STATES TO SUCK
IT UP AND PAY FOR.
THAT IS WHERE THE RUB COMES.
IT IS A HUGE PROBLEM NOT TO
MENTION THOSE WHO COME ARE BEING
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED AND
TRAFFICKED THAT THE HUMAN
TRAGEDY THAT KEEPS GOING, AND
GOING AND WILL PEOPLE BRING
DRUGS AND THEY KILL INNOCENT
AMERICAN TEENAGERS WHO PAYS FOR
THE FUNERAL?
LET ME TELL YOU WE ALL DO.
RACHEL: WE ALL DO.
IT'S HAPPENING PRECISELY THE
TIME SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
STRUGGLING TO PUT GAS IN THEIR
TANK AND FOOD ON THE TABLE.
JUST AS THIS IS HAPPENING WE ARE
SEEING THE STRAIN ON THE
RESOURCES FOR THIS WHOLE WEEKEND
GOVERNOR WE HAVE HAD THIS THING
WITH THE SIDE WERE NOT GOING TO
REPORT THE NEWS WE KEPT ASKING
WHY.
WHY IS THIS HAPPENING?
WHY IS THAT HAPPENING?
WHY DOES THE NEWSPAPER SUDDENLY
DECIDE THE "NEW YORK TIMES"
DECIDE THEY'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE HUNTER BIDEN STORY.
LET'S TALK ABOUT THE Y WITH THIS
POLICY.
BECAUSE I INTERVIEWED TWO WOMEN
WHO WERE RUNNING FOR CONGRESS
WHO HISPANIC WOMEN RUNNING AND
THEY SAID WERE GETTING ALL THESE
HISPANIC VOTERS AMERICAN VOTERS
THEY DON'T LIKE THIS THEY ARE
TURNING TO REPUBLICANS
CANDIDATES BECAUSE THEY'RE NOT
HAPPY ABOUT THIS.
IF THIS IS SO ELECTORALLY BAD
FOR THE DEMOCRATS, WHY DO THEY
KEEP DOING IT?
>> I COULD JUST SAY BECAUSE THEY
HAVE LOST THEIR MINDS BECAUSE I
THINK THEY HAVE.
THAT IS THE OBVIOUS REASON.
I THINK THEY TRULY BELIEVE THEY
ARE GOING TO IMPORT PEOPLE WHO
WILL VOTE FOR THEM FOR THE REST
OF THEIR LIVES.
THEY ARE MISSING SOMETHING.
THE PEOPLE WHO WILL COME HERE,
WHO WILL BE RESPONSIBLE CITIZENS
ARE COMING TO BE RESPONSIBLE
CITIZENS.
THEY WANT TO COME, THEY WILL PAY
TAXES, THEY WILL ABSORB INTO THE
COMMUNITIES, THEY WILL OPEN
BUSINESSES, THEY WILL HELP BRING
PROSPERITY TO THE COUNTRY.
THOSE PEOPLE AND THEY LOOK
AROUND AND SAY WAIT A MINUTE I'M
WORKING REALLY HARD.
DO I REALLY WENT ALL THE THINGS
I'M WORKING FOUR TO SUBSIDIZE
THE PEOPLE WHO GET UP AT THE
CRACK OF NOON AND MAY BE DON'T
TURN A THING UNTIL THE GOATS
THEIR MAILBOX AND PICK UP THEIR
GOVERNMENT CHECK?
THOSE FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE
REPUBLICAN NOT DEMOCRAT.
>> GOVERNOR WE WANT TO TAKE SOME
TIME AND WE HAVE ON THE PROGRAM
TO TALK ABOUT A STORY THAT'S
BEEN TALKED ABOUT ALL WEEK LONG.
BUT THERE'S A NEW ANGLE TO IT IS
IS OF COURSE THE WILL
SMITH/CHRIS ROCK INCIDENT.
THE NEW ANGLES DENZEL WASHINGTON
PRETTY SETS ON THE EARLIER WE
ALL LIKE TO RESET SOMETHING
ABOUT THIS MOMENT AND OH WHAT IT
MEANS MAYBE THE DEEPER ANSWERS
HE WAS AT A LEADERSHIP SUMMIT
SAID THE FOLLOWING.
I DON'T IS THAT WE TALKED ABOUT
MEETING HE AND WILL SMITH.
BUT THERE FOR THE GRACE OF GOD
GO ANY OF US.
WHO ARE WE TO CONDEMN?
I DON'T KNOW THE INS AND OUTS OF
THE SITUATION FOR IT I ONLY
SOLUTION WAS PRAYER.
THERE'S A SAYING THE DEVIL
IGNORE SURE THAN YOU KNOW YOU'RE
DOING SOMETHING WRONG.
THE DEVIL DOES OH NO, LEAVE HIM
ALONE HE'S MY FAVORITE.
CONVERSELY WHEN THE DEVIL COMES
AT YOU MAYBE IT'S BECAUSE YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING RIGHT.
AND FOR WHATEVER REASON THE
DEVIL GOT A HOLE OF HIM THAT
NIGHT.
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT WE WOULD
LOVE TO GET YOUR PERSPECTIVE ON
THIS.
NOT TO EXCUSE WHAT WILL SMITH
DID KNOW IT'S INTERESTED IN THAT
OR JUSTIFY IT.
RATHER LOOK FORWARD.
DENZEL WASHINGTON TALKED WITH
THE ONLY REAL SALVATION IS
PRAYER.
>> I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT COMES OUT OF THIS IT'S
REFRESHING TO HEAR HOLLYWOOD
START LIKE DENZEL WASHINGTON
TALKED ABOUT SPIRITUAL THINGS.
I LOVE THAT.
I APPRECIATE THAT.
ON THIS DAY THAT MOST OF US WILL
BE GOING TO CHURCH YEAR END A
LITTLE WHILE HOW WONDERFUL IT IS
THAT SOMEONE FROM HOLLYWOOD
ACTUALLY HAS THE COURAGE TO SAY
I BELIEVE IN JESUS.
I BELIEVE IN FORGIVENESS.
I BELIEVE IN GRACE AND PRAYER.
THE THINGS THAT ARE REALLY THE
FOUNDATION OF AMERICA'S
GREATNESS AND LIBERTY.
BUT THE THING I HOPE PEOPLE WILL
UNDERSTAND, WHAT WILL SMITH DID
WAS REPREHENSIBLE PARADE WE ALL
UNDERSTAND THAT.
BUT WILL SMITH IS OBVIOUSLY A
HURTING PERSON.
MY PASTOR HAD SAID MANY YEARS
HURT PEOPLE, HURT PEOPLE.
IN OTHER WORDS SOMEONE WHO IS
HURTING WILL END UP HURTING
OTHER PEOPLE.
SOMEWHERE, WILL SMITH IS
HURTING.
WE COULD HOLD HIM ACCOUNTABLE
FOR WHAT HE DID AND WE SHOULD.
BUT WHAT DENZEL WASHINGTON WAS
SHOWING THE EVEN THE MOST
REPREHENSIBLE PERSON IN OUR
MIDST, SOMEONE NEEDS TO BE HIS
FRIEND.
SOMEONE NEEDS TO SHOW HIM LOVE,
FORGIVENESS, GRACE AND KINDNESS.
THAT IS WHY IN AMERICA WE
PROVIDE THE WORST CRIMINALS
AMONG US WITH DEFENSE ATTORNEYS
TO DEFEND THEM AND GUARANTEE
THEM THE CIVIL RIGHTS OF A
TRIAL.
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO SOME PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD.
BUT IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE TO
AMERICANS WHOSE BASIC SYSTEM IS
BUILT ON A RELIGIOUS FOUNDATION
THAT EVERY INDIVIDUAL MATTERS.
EVERY PERSON DOES IN FACT
COUNTS.
WE HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE FOR
THEIR CRIMES.
BUT WE DO NOT HATE THEM.
WE ALSO DO NOT IGNORE THEIR
HUMANITY.
WE TREAT THEM WITH RESPECT AND
DIGNITY WHETHER DID THEY DESERVE
IT OR NOT FOR THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT DENZEL WASHINGTON WAS
SHOWING.
I THINK IT IS JUST SOMETHING TO
CELEBRATE.
AGAIN, HOLD IT WILL SMITH
ACCOUNTABLE FOR HIS SINS.
BUT I'VE ALWAYS SAID WHEN
SOMEONE IS IN TROUBLE THAT IS
WHEN THEY REALLY NEED A FRIEND
AND WE CAN ACT MORE LIKE
CHRISTIANS THAN THAN ANY OTHER
TIME IN OUR LIVES.
FOLKS QUITE A PRE-SERMON
APPETIZER WE ARE ALL SINNERS
SAVED ONLY BY GRACE AND MOMENTS
LIKE THIS REMIND US OF THAT.
WE COULD ALL BE THE SAME
SITUATION.
RACHEL: REMINDER HE IS A
GOVERNOR FROM A FORMER GOVERNOR
BUT HE IS A PASTOR FIRST.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WE CAN TELL.
PASTOR/GOVER